- Okay, welcome everybody.
These are the Franke Lectures
in the Humanities at the
Whitney Humanities Center.
I'm Paul North,
and the series is called
The Value of Marx's Capital.
It is a companion to an
undergraduate seminar,
that I'm giving at Yale
and the students are here
in attendance, or we'll be,
and it's also in concert
with a new translation
that's being done by my
colleague, Paul Reitter at OSU.
And in addition, we're calling
a Critical Student Edition
a Critical Reading Edition,
in which I'm co-writing the notes.
So we're exploring the book together,
and before we start, I
need to thank a few people.
The Franke Lectures are made possible
by the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke.
And are intended to
present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience.
I would like to thank Alice Kaplan
the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center,
for making this possible
metaphysically possible
for those who made it
organizationally possible,
Sandra Malan-Bowles and
Leana Hirschfeld Kroen.
And for those meaning
one person, Audrey Leak
who's making it technologically possible.
Thank you Audrey, thank you to everyone.
We are going to start
with our presentation from our speaker
and then we will turn to
the audience for questions.
Please hold your questions.
When I give you the signal,
you can start putting them
in the chat and we'll go
through them that way.
I'd like to start with a
quote from the speaker.
So this is a quote from a great book.
Marx's temporalities
from 2013 from a section
on laws and tendencies.
I'm gonna read this quote.
"Marx's tried to delineate tendencies
"in the same way that a
painter begins to paint
"the background before painting
the subjects of the picture.
"The historical tendencies are sketched
"out in order better to give evidence
"of the nature of the counter tendencies.
"By the middle of the 1860s, at least Marx
"was decisively opposed
to the quote idolatry
"of the rigidity of laws in history."
Unquote.
"Just as capitalism is not
digging its own grave by itself,
"equally communism is not an ontological
"dimension already produced in capital.
"It is necessary rather to work
"in the space of the difference,
between law and tendency."
This is a quote from our
speaker Massimiliano Tomba,
and I'm gonna give the
screen over to my colleague,
Paul Reitter, to introduce him.
- Thanks Paul,
and Massimiliano thank you
so much for being here.
Massimiliano Tomba, is
a professor of politics,
and also the history of consciousness
at the University of
California at Santa Cruz,
and the history of consciousness program,
is such a wonderful thing
really a legendary program,
and it's great that he's there.
He is the author
of a number of books on
Marx and other topics.
Most recently, a book entitled titled
"Insurgent Universality
and "Alternative Legacy of
Modernity" published in 2019.
Paul mentioned his
Marxist temporalities book
which was published in 2013.
He's also written the book about content
Benjamine, and a book on Bruno
Bowers, political categories.
He, a lot of his thinking turns
on Temporality,
historiography time in Marx,
and he has a number
of articles that that
deal with those topics.
I hope that this has suggested something
about how broadly interested he is in Marx
and how open his scholarship is.
A lot of people, we were
talking about this earlier,
Paul and I and Massimiliano, how a lot
of people claim that they
have re they are interested
in really opening things up now,
in this era of post
sectarian, Marxist criticism,
and yet they cling mostly to
a certain idea perspective way
of reading and there is a real openness
in the Massimiliano scholarship,
that I certainly appreciate a great deal.
So thank you so much for being
part of this Massimiliano.
It's great to meet you
and to have you here.
The title of the presentation
today is Nothing To Expect
But Tanning Bodies at work.
- Thank you so much for inviting me.
I want to start with the two anecdotes.
One is the personnel and
it concerns my youth.
When I was a 14, my
father basically sent me,
during the summer send me to work
in the small factory, in my village.
And after a couple of days, I was there,
I was looking at my watch,
because it was 4:30 almost 5:00 PM.
At 5:00 PM is the working days over,
I was looking for that time.
And then another worker, colleague
look at me and he told me
"What are you doing?
"Put your watch back into your pocket.
"If the boss sees you that
you are looking at your watch,
"he starts screaming like crazy."
I said, "Oh, wow."
And it was my second day.
I'm like, well, it was the 14.
And the the second anecdote,
is about another guy whose
name is Good Channel.
And once he had the to introduce himself,
and he was a real factory worker.
For me was just the
experience over one summer.
And he introduced himself
by saying, "I have worked
"for 30 years in that factory."
Then is he silent himself,
I think that life is not
just a second, sorry.
I'm very sorry for that.
And then he said, "Actually
it's not that I worked,"
actually he said "I have
been worked, for 30 years."
So why did I start with
these two anecdotes?
Because the first one
it show me, at that time
I couldn't understand
exactly what was going on.
But the first time about
looking at my watch,
it shows me what, that
the time when you are
in the factory time doesn't belong to you.
And the second example,
the second anecdote,
the body that has been worked.
It shows that even the body
may be doesn't belong to you.
So when you are a factory worker,
you sell your labor power,
but unfortunately for you
your body is attached to
that commodity labor power.
And at that point, even the
body is not really yours.
You have to be subjected to
a very specific discipline,
and not only is very often,
you have to be subjected
to a kind of a very noxious labor,
that really consumed your body.
But in that second example
there even something more.
Because in that transition from I worked,
in to, I have been worked,
I see the transition
from active to passive.
And the passive form, that
is very present in capital
volume one, is very tricky,
because immediately,
forces us to think whose agency is that.
When I say I have been
worked, who is the agent?
Whose agency is that?
So, and this is the starting
point of my presentation.
I want to share my screen with you.
So, when Marx wants to describe,
or to point out this agent,
he uses Gothic images,
in these case is Dante.
And is the hell, is the infernal.
And Marx sites, Dante and he writes,
I want to read from my, yeah.
He writes, "With a working
day ranging from 12 to 14
or 15 hours, night-labor,
irregular meal-times,
and meals mostly taken in
the workrooms themselves,
pestilent with the phosphorous.
Dante would have found the
worst horrors, in his Inferno
Surpassed in this industry.
This is how he presents the factory,
as a hell, as an Inferno.
And then as I say, we move
in to this gothic images.
My question is, I want
to repeat my question.
Whose agency is that?
Whose the agent of, "I have been worked"
Marx,
describes the Capital as a data labor,
which vampyre on like,
leaves only by sacking leaving labor.
Marx read the Polidori,
this book that was published
in 1819, and he uses the image
of The Vampyre many times.
For example, and now the citation
The Vampyre thirst for the
leaving blood of labor.
Or to gain The Vampyre,
will not let the worker go,
while there remains a single muscle
or drop of blood to be exploited.
So the language is very physical,
corporeal, muscle, blood.
And Capital is described as a Vampyre.
Sometime Marx uses a different image.
It's not The Vampyre,
but it's The Wehr-Wolf.
And Marx is talking about The Wehr-Wolf,
like The Wehr-Wolf
hunger for surplus labor.
He also describes the factory
and the condition of a
labor in The capitalist Mode
of Production as the torture
of a CC force, other images.
This is again, it's not
Dante, but in Dante,
you can find that these
torture of Assisi force
as a form of punishment.
Again in other image of that the Marx use,
I'm just going to hold
these different images
and other images that Marx
uses, is the Juggernaut.
And the
(mumbles)
of the Juggernaut wheels of a capital.
And these Juggernaut,
this car is a kind of a huge way of,
bearing an image of an Hindu God.
The term Juggernaut was
also used in literature
for example, it was used
to describe, the character
of Mr. Hyde in Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde.
Marx read all these kind of
Novels, and he used all of them
to describe, or to give some images
of the capitalist model production.
He also another citation now,
in order to, wanna go deeper
in Marx's considerations
of these bodies at work.
Marx described the factory in terms of,
in the bodies of the workers,
in terms of say, I quote,
"Physical and mental degradation."
He's talking about the
torture of the overwork.
He also writes that the
factory work exhaust
the nervous system of the worker
and confiscates every atom
of a freedom, both in bodily
and in intellectual activity.
I think this is important.
So Marx is aware that the
labor is consuming both
the body and the soul.
Your body in your intellect.
And the now the question is,
why is the Marx using all these images?
What does it want to provoke?
One can say, "Oh, is in
order to provoke a kind
"of a more indignation."
I'm not sure about that.
Maybe a little, but not
really, in my opinion.
Why, because Marx doesn't
represent the capitalist.
I always say so far
capitalist mode of production,
or capital.
Marx doesn't represent the capitalist
as an evil monster.
Actually in the preface
of a capital volume one,
when you talking about the capitalist,
he says that he considers the capitalistic
a personified category.
When Marx uses the term
monster, and he uses the term,
and he uses this term in order to describe
the capitalist machine.
or yeah, the machine,
which Marx portrayed as I quote,
"A mechanical monster, whose
body feels the old factory,
and whose demonic power
burst forth in the fast
and feverish wheel of his
countless working organs.
So the monster is the mechanical monster,
that Marx describes also
as a body whose organs
are the workers.
And there is a power, and
Marx describes this power
as a demonic power.
So it's interesting the fact
that he uses all these images,
these concept, evil, monster, demonic,
in order to describe machinery
and not in order to
describe the capitalist
as a person, as a subject.
For that reason, I don't
think there is a or...
Yes, it's there, but it's not a Sentra.
There is not to be a more condemnation
of the capitalist mode of production.
There is something more,
we have to go a little bit
deeper to see what these stake
in capital volume one.
So the capitalist is not an evil agent.
That's in order to provoke
a little bit the discussion,
I am not sure that Marx,
would have shared some
of the moral condemnation
on the 1% that was very
common and the still
common in occupy.
He would have agreed for
sure, with a political
and social motivation,
but maybe not with the
moralistic language.
Maybe, these are just something
that we can discuss later.
Because as I said, for
Marx the capitalist,
is a personified the category.
The agency, that was our first question
whose agency is that,
when we are talking about,
"I have been worked."
In the agency is according to Marx
is that, or the subject is in Marx,
is the automatic subject.
This is a Marx's store.
And what is the automatic
subject, is a value.
Is a process.
Is it volatilization of value.
Very quickly, what is the
valorization of value?
What is the process of valorization?
I can only, we can go back
in the discussion, if you want.
The only thing I want to say is
that when we are talking
about valorization,
the crucial category or concept is time.
And that was my second anecdote,
it was my first anecdote.
The second was of body,
the first one was a time.
The central concept is time.
So basically for Marx the value,
is a socially necessarily labor time,
objectified in one commodity.
But what does it mean?
It means that the value
is not that the time,
that you usually, you
actually require in order
to produce a certain commodity.
One capitalist maybe needs three hours
in order to produce the pan,
another capital is
because he has machines,
he can produce the same pan in one hour.
Marx's point, is, the
value is exactly the same
because the value is socially
necessarily labor time
objectified in the commodity.
So it kind of average.
And this is interesting,
because it allows us to understand
a very interesting phenomenon.
Again, we can talk about
that in the discussion.
So, but the phenomenon,
is how different capitals,
work in the global
market and in competition
with each other.
So in a certain way, for a
capital that is extremely
or can use labor, it is
extremely productive,
because it has machine
that can produce things,
one pain in one hour, but in
order to have these advantage,
the advantage is he can
produce things faster
quicker than the socially
necessary labor time,
what is necessary is that,
in the entire society
there are other capitalists
which cannot use machine.
Or maybe they can, but
they don't have the money
to buy the machine.
So capitalism is not a
normal genius system.
Capitalism requires
differences in productivity.
And these differences are
unnecessary in order to gain,
and realize what Marx
calls extra surplus value.
So in a certain way, my point is,
if you want to understand,
I'm working in California.
If you want to understand
the Silicon Valley,
you need to understand Foxconn in China.
You need to understand how these
two systems are connected.
Are part of the same configuration.
How high tech production is combined
with the gigantic factories
in which you have thousands
and thousands of workers.
And I think Marx
allows us to understand
this kind of a relationship,
that is I think very crucial today,
because otherwise the risk is to think
and this is my last
provocation for the discussion,
otherwise the risk is I
think that automation,
can get rid of human labor.
I think is not the case.
Why, because capital requires
differences in productivity.
Capital is allergic to
the, what Marx called
the generalization, of a
technological innovation.
We can talk about that.
Then there is another they mentioned
that is important to
emphasize in the process
of a valorization.
So one is time, and the other
one is that is a process
is a limitless.
It doesn't have boundaries.
So that means, and I'm going
back to my topic bodies.
So that means that we can say
that the computer is mode of
production is characterized
by attention, by a conflict,
between limit and limitless.
Limitless is the process of
valorization as Marx define it.
What is the limit?
The limit is that workers
have only one body.
The body is a kind of a limit,
for the capitalist mode of production.
And not only bodies, but Marx
says also soil and nature.
So if there is a reason why capitalism
or the capitalist model of
production is a sole distractive.
It's not because the capitalist is evil.
Capitalist or the mode of the
capitalist mode of production
is so distractive because it's limitless.
Okay, now it's time to
go back to our shop test.
And there is a timer in this,
- Marx your light went off again we think.
There we go.
- Yeah, and I don't know
how to de-activate is time.
It's not my office.
I will say yes, we can go back
to chapter four, five, six
and maybe I have to speed up a little bit.
So chapter four, five, six,
are three chapters, three
distinguished chapters
only in the English
edition, for some reason.
I think the German edition
is one big chapter.
Actually in the first edition, 1867,
it's a long second chapter,
because even the first part,
was not divided in chapters.
So what do we call four,
five, six as the chapters,
is just one piece.
And in the 1890 edition is the same.
What you can see is the second part,
that is divided in paragraphs,
but it is one chapter,
chapter four and not four, five, six.
Chapter five, the field Das Kapital,
is what in the English
edition is a chapter seven.
Why is this important?
It's important only for one reason,
that the you have to read
and you have to consider
these four or three chapters as one piece.
Like a theatrical piece.
There is a big eating, there
is something in the middle,
there is something at the end
but not the three chapters,
is one big piece.
Is a long chapter.
And the beginning, is
the first pages of this
longer chapter is about the
circulation of commodities.
Marx writes everyday, everyday
the same story is played
out before our eyes on the stage.
What we can find there,
is this Marx again,
are economic dramatis persona.
Marx, he uses the Latin, and
then you will see this a term,
we'll come back at the very
end of this long chapter.
What you can find on the stage
is a buyer and the seller.
Basically what you can find
is equal formerly equal
in juridical subject.
And when Marx introduces the
capitalist is very co-even
with what he said in the preface.
He says the capitalist,
I quote, "Is the person
"or rather is a pocket.
"Is something that
functions as a capitalist"
Is a capital personified.
And this is what we can see on the stage.
You have to imagine this stage
in which you have a seller and buyers,
and they sell and buy
commodities and labor power
is it just one commodity amongst others.
But then it's problem is,
okay, where value is produced.
And then in the middle,
literally in the middle
of this long chapter, Marx writes,
"Something must take
place in the background,
"which is not the visible
in the circulation itself."
Valorization and the creation of value.
So the first dimension is
the stage, the appearance,
something that is played
out before our eyes.
Then Marx introduces a second layer,
"Something must take
place in the background,
"that is not the visible."
And now at the very end of this chapter,
he abandons the sulphase .
The sphere where buyers and sellers,
buy and sell their commodities.
Where they buy and sell labor power.
And this is the sphere of the circulation,
that the Marx describes as a, I quote,
"In full view of everyone" end quote.
But at the very end, last page
of this along the chapter.
Marx move into the hidden
a board of product.
And you're right.
When we leave this sphere
of a simple circulation,
or the exchange of commodities,
which provides the free-trader vulgaris,
which his views his
concept and the standard
by which he judges the society
of capital and wage labor,
a certain change takes
place, or so it appears
in the physionomy of
our dramatis personae.
He began with the dramatis personea
on the stage circulation.
Formerly free and equal subjects.
But now he says, "A
certain change takes place
"in the physionomy of
these dramatis personae."
These masks, these actors, these actors
He who was the previously
the money-owner, now strides
out in front as a
capitalist: the possessor
of the labor power follows as its worker.
The one smirks self- importantly,
and ease intent on
business, the capitalist.
The other, the worker
is timid and holds back
like someone who has brought
his own hide to market
and now as nothing else
to expect, but a tanning.
I think these is a powerful ending,
and again, the structure of
this book is really important.
Because if a chapter one, two,
three, are about commodity,
abstract labor fetishism, money.
Then we have these part two
chapter four, five, six,
one chapter in which we
can see that the transition
from circulation into production.
And then we have part three
and four, in which basically we
see human beings with their
bodies, into the hidden abode
of production.
And you see how value is produced,
and how these bodies, suffer
because of that condition.
If you want to, we can make a short break,
or I can go ahead it's up to you.
I have other, I don't know,
something like 15 minutes maybe
or maybe less, but it's up to.
- No I think it's fine
why don't you go ahead.
- Okay, so as I said, at
the end of this chapter,
the discourse becomes extremely concrete.
It's no longer about abstract categories
Marx needs, history.
Marx needs a lot of
footnotes and citations
from the factory report.
He has to show how this system works.
And as I said, this course
is not just about to bail you
as abstract category.
Is about,
it's not about the commodity
as something abstract
as a just exchange
value, Marx is interested
in what he calls a especially commodity.
In Germany is a specific shape body.
There is a special commodity,
and these special commodity is the worker.
And these are special, I
would say for two reasons.
One is because labor
power is the commodity
that can valorize the value.
We know this story, but this is special
because it's the only
commodity that is attached
to what Marx call, a living body,
(speak foreign language)
So labor power exists only in workers.
And the labor power is
that there's an aggregate
of the mental and physical capabilities,
which exists I'm citing
Marx in the physical form
the leaving personality of a human being.
So I think this is crucial
for many different reasons.
And it's crucial for what I said before.
If the valorization process is limitless
and Marx actually defines
these a process as limitless
in chapter three,
before this theatrical
transition into the production.
So if valorization is limitless
the point is if we want
to address a critique
of the capitalist model
for action, we should find,
what is the limit of
this limitless system,
or structure or process.
So the critique is in
the tension between limit
and limitless
And I think, that tension
makes the entire project,
we can discuss about that,
that make the project possible.
The project of a capital volume
one as subtitled a critique
of a political economy.
So from that perspective,
what we can see is that the
image we had on the stage
at the level of a circulation is force.
The sellers and the buyers no
longer juridical comparisons.
Are no longer free and equals.
Now, they are workers,
in the process of a production,
and they are not equal.
There is a huge asymmetries
under production.
We will see the cemetery
thing back in the second.
And the second thing is about
is exactly what I said,
is the tension between
limit and limitless.
This is other citation,
I think is the last one.
And this is from the end, the last page
of the chapter on the working day.
And you can see something
similar, Marx is saying now,
yeah, it must be a knowledge
that our worker emerged
from the process of a
production looking differently
from when he entered,
the contract by which
he sold his labor power
to the capitalist approved in
black and white so to speak,
that he was free to dispose of himself.
But, when the transaction was
concluded, it was discovered
that it was not free agent.
That the period of time
of which is a free to seal
his labor power, is the period
of time for which is forced
to sell it.
That in fact, The Vampyre will not let go,
while there remains a
single muscle sinew drop
of blood to be exploited.
So what do we call freedom at the level
of a juridical subjects form
the equality formal freedom
laws is no longer freedom
when we take a look at this,
the workers within the production.
So at the least there are
two concepts of freedom.
Not only there is something even more,
what it's not possible at
level of a circulation,
the fact that these are juridical freedom,
legal freedom is actually not freedom.
These contradiction the sanigation
of the juridical freedom
is only visible from the
perspective of production.
So for that reason, these
are movement from circulation
to production is necessary
in order to dis-unveil.
the mystification that takes place
at the level of the circulation.
And if we emphasize a little
bit to the term unveil,
we can say that the unveil
is adjust to translation
of the Greek term Aletheia,
that means unveil.
It is that the production is
the truth of the entire mode
of production capitalist model production.
Because it shows that the
what happens said to the level
of the circulation is force,
and it shows something
more that is not visible
from the perspective of a circulation.
From the perspective of circulation,
you see quality and freedom,
you don't see the assymetry
and the distraction of bodies.
I think this is the reason
why Marx's perspective
on workers' bodies is
a kind of a, is a key.
Is if kosher, in order to address
his materialist historiography,
or maybe in order to develop
a materialistic choreography.
For that reason, he goes
into, as I said before
into the factory reports, the
archive on workers bodies.
And not only a kind of have a
sufferance, but also archive
in which we can find workers resistance.
Why resistance is possible,
or even necessarily
as I said, because this is
the clash, this is the tension
between limit at the limitless.
If the capitalist mode of
production doesn't encounter
any limit is just a pure distraction.
Maybe even self distraction,
something that we can discuss.
So going back to the gothic imaginary,
the term monster, occurs another time,
one more time in capital.
But now it denotes the
worker, that Marx described
as a converted into a creeper monstrosity
by the manufacturer.
The term monstrosity is
it's not really a right
to an explanation because
the German term is abnormitat
So the worker becomes something abnormal.
And for that reason, Marx uses terms like,
industrial pathology.
Physical deterioration.
Moral degradation.
Intellectual degeneration.
Process of distraction.
This is the terminology.
Again, I want to emphasize,
I want to be very clear
about that, not because
of the capital is evil,
but because the process is limitless.
And we have to think one
something about this canactive
being limitless of the Capital.
Maybe for the discussion.
Because maybe exacting the fact,
for the Capital is limitless,
there is something quiet
attractive in the capital
is mode of production
Something that I think we should discuss.
So I say that the
capital has been written,
"Thanks or because of
the workers resistance."
So we have a question
to conclude this is now
read the conclusion.
What is the resistance
and how resistance work?
So if we focused on bodies,
we have to say first
that the body is something
extremely individual.
We can share ideas, we can share opinions,
but this is my body.
Then the capitalist mode
of production is the cause
of our shard condition.
Why, because the capitalist
mode of production converts
workers body into a monstrosity,
into organ of the machine as the most.
So we share something that
I'm able to call, is a kind
of a common condition of exploitation,
or you can call it the kind
of a negative universality.
We all are exploited.
We all suffer.
But my emphasis is on these
negative universality.
And I don't think we can
do so much with a negative
or universality.
But again, that can be
part of our discussion.
Because why, because there
is a third of the level.
And the third level is that
there is something more,
there is another form of being in common,
and maybe there is a link
between the uniqueness
of individual bodies and
something collective.
Something that we can
describe as a social body.
Marx doesn't use the term social body,
Marx uses the term capitalist corporation,
when has to describe how
workers have been put together
in a factory, and he uses
the term associates Arbeit,
associations when he
describes it different form
of Associations of workers sell for,
I don't wanna use the
term self-organization.
Our workers have a different
form of being together.
I wanna explain that.
Because, in what we can
call a kind of a common
collective social body,
we can see something more what
the workers share is not just
the Common condition of being exploited.
They share experiences, culture,
traditions, even the past
in some sometimes.
So in a certain way, the
social body can be read
as if the result of a double process,
I use again more than times
that you don't find in Marx.
The result of the double
process of de-subjectivation,
and re-subjectivation.
And is this my really last citation.
Kind of a it's not gonna
feel this association.
And, yeah Marx is
describing, the associations
of workers in France.
What is important, what is
crucial in this citation?
Is that the togetherness,
the being together becomes an end.
The associations is not instrumental.
These artisans, these
worker do not associate,
because they have to
achieve an external goal.
Yes, also, because of that.
But in the process,
of association, they
enjoy, it alternative,
a different form of togetherness.
That becomes the goal.
That becomes the end in
itself and not the means
to another end.
I think in my opinion, this is a crucial
and I think is important for two reasons.
First because what I call
this a double process
of de-subjectivation and re-subjectivation
is just an expression or is
the practice of association
it's not a theory.
We can ask why does Marx
not to describe socialism
or communism in the book?
Because this is not the theory.
There is not theory of socialism,
there is not theory of
another form of being together
or togetherness.
There is not the theory,
this is a practice.
And Marx is humble enough.
I don't think he was very humble,
but in any case is humble
enough, to a knowledge,
that in that case workers artisans
they are one step ahead.
They are theory in actions.
They show us, what these different form
of togetherness looks like.
- And where is this citation from?
Where is this quote from?
- This is from the manuscript,
when Marx went to France.
1844.
- Oh, this is from the
economic and philosophical.
- Yeah.
So I wanted to end it with this citation,
because I want to end by
saying that the politics
in this book, or maybe the
politics we need today,
and we can extract form this book.
It's not just the politics of an empty.
What I call the negative universality.
There is something more,
and there is a kind of
anticipation of a different forms
of associality.
And in a certain way Marx
took this perspective,
both of exploitation,
but also the way workers
organize themselves, and
they are able to reinvent
for purpose of associality
as an anticipation of an attendant.
And this is actually
the strategic viewpoint
that the we should adopt in
order to reconsider a critique
of the capitalist mode of production.
That's it.
- Thank you so much.
This is the time where
there's thunderous applause.
I like to mention it would be here.
We thank you very much for the talk.
I wanna, we're gonna open up to questions,
so if folks want to put
their questions in the chat,
we will get to them.
I'm gonna start with a question.
I have a lot of them, but maybe
I'll ask you in your reading
of capital, where does the limitlessness
of capital come from?
Is that a kind of fiction
that proceeds under?
Is it a matter of law?
The reason I quoted your quote on laws,
because you never let people
you never let Marx become
dogmatic even himself,
and I appreciate that about you.
But you could read him as quite dogmatic
that limitlessness arises from
the composition of capital
or arises from competition,
necessary competition.
It's unstoppable until the
whole thing falls apart.
If ever if that's, you know
or the planet falls apart.
So where do you think
limitlessness comes from,
and do you see the, these limits,
the worker's body, there's
other that he names right?
The working day, the organic
composition of capital,
how do they stop being
enabling limits, let's say,
of capital's drive,
and how do they start
being resisting limits?
- Yeah, I would say this
is my understanding.
So the limitless in the book in the text,
it comes up when Marx
describes the process
of money commodity money first.
So it's a process in
which basically the aim
of the entire process of
production is to valorize value
and to gain more value
than the amount of value
that you put in the process.
Yes, then you have a
first implication of that,
that basically they use value
of the commodities you produce
if in a certain way,
indifferent, what do you need
in Marx terms, is you need
better trigger of exchange value.
This is the only thing you need,
So the capital or the
capitalist in this case,
can produce books or
gas is exactly the same.
The point is you need a commodity
in which value is objectified
and then you can sell these commodities
in order to realize more value and so on.
So they use the value
becomes kind of an abstract
in the three first chapters.
There you have a decent
process, that just a process
of a is limitless because
they only end is to increase
the value more and more.
But then this is the thing.
Then you have a very specific use value.
Is a user values are different
at the level of commodities,
there is a special
commodity, whose use value,
is not indifferent.
And this is the worker.
Unfortunately for the capitalist,
when you buy labor power
you have the worker of this worker.
Yes you have the body of this worker,
unfortunately for the capital is why?
Because these commodity can resist.
This commodity is toolbolate
This commodity doesn't
love to be exploited.
This commodity can make trouble.
And this is where the story
begins, in my opinion.
So it begins at the level
of use values are abstract
with the exception of one
use value, that is the worker
that is not abstract,
and constitutes a tension
with the process of valorization.
So you can squeeze almost everything
but you can squeeze the human
being only to a certain point.
- Okay, that's really great, thank you.
Let's open it up the chat
here, and we'll ask to unmute,
there's a comment from
Phillip Volvstutter.
Marx says that capital turns
every limit into a barrier.
I'll just read that out.
But then there are, let's
see if there's a question.
Okay, there's mostly comments here.
Would the people like
to make their comments?
Terra would you like to make your comment?
Why don't we unmute, professor Carver.
If you don't mind.
You might have to unmute yourself
- Okay, no, that's fine, happy to comment.
Sorry I got started to writing a lecture
cause there was a little
discussion going on here
about limits and so
values and how that works
out in capital.
So I very much period of the lecture
and the discussion of imagery
and the theatrical analogies
and personifications that are going on.
I think that's very helpful.
The particular discussion
was about why capital should
go on forever, 'cause
that's kind of the notion
that you put out turns out.
I think Marx's his angle on
that is that a value is set
up to be something very abstract,
and so purely mathematical
in a certain aspect.
So it's an abstract representation
that something that
actually exists concretely.
Since it's abstract, and
since it's particularly
quantitative mathematic, in
fact purely quantitative,
mathematic pulling it's abstract aspect.
It's limitless going to go on forever.
So anything that seems to be a limit
or a barrier is going to be translate of,
got over with via the
limitlessness of abstraction.
So this is, you know I mean
borrowing off of Hegel's logic
and you can pay at the
same place with Derrida,
really, that is concept,
so imply the opposites
that are defined by the others,
so anything contains its opposite.
So if you work abstractly
obviously everything goes around
in the round like that Marx
is I think really saying
that we've trapped ourselves,
through the commodity
pricing value system,
it's just something that
makes us chase abstract,
quantification and quantification is
increasing without limits.
So I think it's set up that
way, it's very powerful.
It ties into the discussion
about the monster machine
and so all the other kinds
of unstoppable desires
that are here very
personal kind of imagery.
- Thank you.
- No thank you.
- Yeah, I think when, if we
consider a value as abstract.
And I think in the
first, as I said before,
the first implication of
that is that, the use value
as I said, becomes a kind of a simple,
better of value.
And the implication of that,
is that basically the process
of an valorization, is
indifferent to meet,
to the limit, to the limitless
of natural the sources.
So everything becomes a kind
of a limited that is external
to that process.
So the point is that in
itself, capital is a kind
of a mechanism of self distraction.
But because there are so many limits,
it doesn't destroy itself.
It doesn't like capital doesn't
like the fact that there are
limits, but at the same time
the fact that there are out of limits,
makes the capitalist model
production extremely dynamic.
He has to adjust the existence of a limit.
For example, Marx writes
when there is a strike
the capital's answer is a new machine.
Maybe it's not the cause of the reaction
but it's a way that capital
likes to replace a worker,
so when the machine, but then
it increases productivity,
and then it has other problems.
But yes, I think we have
just to consider the fact
that the capitalist mode of production
is extremely flexible, extremely dynamic,
and for that reason, it can
last for very long time.
What is maybe what is the
last limit that capital
is facing now, maybe
it's a climate change.
Capital can really go so far
that it can destroyed the planet.
But then these are not an EpiHandy.
- Right not for anybody.
- No.
- Okay we have a question
from kind of comment question
from Michael
Michael if you would be
willing to restate it
will open you up.
- Yeah, sure thank you.
And look, it's, I'm not trying
to be annoying cause I don't
I kind of don't really care
about the thing I value
in Marx is not the moral critique.
But I guess I was just,
I'm trying to draw out,
the point you're making about evil.
I think capitalist
doesn't need to be able,
you're saying that Marx
probably wouldn't engage
in a moral critique of the 1%.
And I just had a question about that.
I guess like a capitalism
doesn't need to be able
to play their role.
It's irrelevant like in the account in--
Well, there needs to be
evil in the sense of wanting
to produce suffering, but it seems to me
that they do in the sense of,
they need to be indifferent
to the suffering produced
by tryna get limitless value
out of limited things
like human bodies.
The person who ran the,
the factory that your friend
was worked in for 30 years
like needed to be indifferent
to the effect that the
impact that that had on him.
Does that count as a kind
of able, until the degree
that the capitalist ,
is playing is personified
capital has to act
in the interests of
capital to that degree.
Are they playing an evil role
in the same way that an actor
in a production doesn't have to
be able to play an evil character,
but within the theatrical framework,
and in this case in the
framework of production,
they're doing something
with evil effects, right?
- Yep, I think, thank
you for your question.
I think we can easily say
that the capital is maybe
more cynical than evil.
But this not the question,
this is not the point.
The point is that is not so useful
to use it moral categories
in order to analyze
or criticize the capitalist
mode of production.
I think this is my point.
Why?
Because the implication is,
okay so then if we use a
moral categories, one can ask,
okay why don't do we
modernize the capitalist model
production, and manage what they've said,
"Unfortunately, you cannot."
And why, because it doesn't
depend on the capitalist,
to do what it's doing.
Is in the game, because of
the competition of capitals.
In a certain way even the
most brutal capitalist
can even that I present
himself, as a good human being
because he can say, or she can
say, "Oh, look at the list.
"I giving a job to all these people
"that otherwise can start."
I don't buy it, but from
a capitalist perspective
you know, a shakey job
is better than no job.
And so this is the thing.
And so it's, I think it's important to,
or I would say I follow
Marx in this understanding
of the capitalist mode production,
without moral categories
because I think it's either,
because I think it's not,
it's just not possible
to modernize the system.
This is the political implications.
So another thing is important
when we read this book
is that I think every single passage
in this book have been written
from the perspective of the
possible political implication.
So Marx is not just the scientist,
that gives us a representation
of the capitalist mode
of production is thinking
of the political implication
of what is saying and what this doing.
And I think, yeah, for that reason,
he's not so politically useful
to attack the capitalist
as an evil agent.
- That's really useful.
I would add to that in your
presentation, the picture
of labor as losing its agency
and the picture of capital is not really
the capitalist is not having any to begin
with excludes morality,
which is a free act
of an agent that was not caught
up in a system like that.
If you don't mind reading your
question, would be terrific.
- [Woman] Is that?
- [Paul North] Hello.
- [Woman] Hi.
So, yeah, thanks so much.
I actually didn't know about
the chapters being one chapter.
The question is when you
talked about like the body
and human being, do you
mean ontologically or
in recognition of kind of a
difference in toil, the bodies
across kind of the world or
different geographic areas take.
And then more importantly than that,
can we think kinda both
of them together in yeah.
Just kind of, can we fit
them both together in a way?
- Maybe if I can say it is
an ontological dimension
but I don't like the
term oncology so much.
And I usually I avoid to use it.
But yes, I think it's at
the level of an ontology,
but I would put it differently.
I would put it in this
way that I can go back
to that the worker, so Luchano.
When the worker says, I have a been walked
maybe it's phenomenological
more than ontological.
What does it mean when you
say I have been worked?
What does it mean when you say
after 30 years, my back hurt a lot.
I'm sick and so on.
What does it mean?
It means that the, the process
of what Marx would have called
the deterioration degradation
of your body, is what that process went
to something that is extremely
artificial, not natural.
It's not that the, your body hurts
because you are getting old.
Is because it has been consumed.
And then you're at a political
theoretical implications.
So the consumption of the labor
power is at the same time,
the consumption of your body and your soul
and your intellect.
Is not because of this
is an extremely hard
or the factory work.
I think the same thing happens
in today with workers who have to work
at their computers for 10 hours a day.
What is the result at the end
of the day, there are many
many increased interviews with the workers
who do this kind of job,
at the end of the day the meaning is,
you have a headache, your back hurt,
and what you want to do is to go to bed.
So these are kind of
what I'm talking about,
I suppose there's a kind
of a finger terminology
of the body, that goes
through this process.
And they think the theoritical
assumption of that is,
again, if this attention,
this conflict between
the limitless process
of a valorization, and the fact that,
we have to accept the fact
that the body as easily
in the condition of finitude.
And what happens when you
put together the finitude
of the body and the
limitless mode of production.
This is my simple question.
- Yeah, that's a, it's
an important question.
It does seem like the
limitlessness is not,
it doesn't seem to sustain
itself without draining,
the life out of finite lives, that's true.
Okay I wanna go to,
I think one more question
from Liz Kinnaman.
Liz do you want to, we unmute
you and your present cat
thank you.
- Okay, so it's kind of in
paragraph form, I'll just read it
out loud.
Because of Marx's references
to intellectual activity
and mental degradation,
which kind of stood
out to me in this presentation in capital.
Do you think it's fair to say
that he's always been
talking about what Lazaretto
and others would call it immaterial labor.
I'm just curious about your
thoughts on the Fortist,
post Fortis, labor distinction
and whether you think immaterial
labor being hegemonic,
makes resistance more
challenging precisely
'cause it takes place in
the psyche or the mind.
- Yeah, thank you for this question.
So my problem with the expression,
with the statement in material
labor, being hegemonic,
is the term hegemonic, and
those for the term immaterial.
When we're talking about
material labor, again
there is something very material
in the immaterial labor.
When we're talking about the
internet or communication,
we are also talking about two things.
We're talking about the
cables under the oceans,
which make this system possible.
And they are very material.
And someone has to produce
these things and sometime
and someone has to place
these cables under the ocean.
And so there is a
materiality in the material,
in the immaterial labor.
But this is just the secondary critic.
My main critique is that
this is a very stages
theological understanding of
capitalist model production.
When you say, Oh, this is hegemonic,
I think yes, maybe hegemonic
in part of the U.S,
part of Europe, Canada,
but there are three fourth
of the planet in which immaterial
labor is not hegemonic.
So even in California,
where you find the Silicon
Valley, there is a central Valley
in which 800,000 workers
are employed in agriculture
and they generate something
like 54 billions of dollars.
So the point is that, it's not that,
Oh, agriculture is residua,
and Silicon Valley is a hegemonic.
Or as a negative try to correct is fine,
is intentionally hegemonic.
Because some people from
polo post-colonial studies,
criticized is Eurocentrism
so it's not hegemonic
in three, four holds the war.
Then you can say, Oh, yes Marx
is intensionally hegemonic.
No.
I think that the difficult task
is to combine the two things.
I want to read, I want to see a theory,
and I don't think Marx is almost there,
that is able to combine Silicone
Valley and central Valley.
Agriculture and software.
And how these two things work together.
How these two things
are combined together.
So these is a theoretical political effort
because otherwise, I think
it's adjusted a new barstion
of a theological conception of history,
and in the 20th century,
industrial labor was hegemonic,
and agriculture was a
backward or residual.
Now the material labor is hegemonic
and the industrial labor is a residual.
I don't buy it.
These different forms of
exploitations co-exist.
What do we have to explain
is the co existence,
not the fact that the one is hegemonic
or will be hegemonic, or is a
tender tendensually hegemonic.
This is my, I won't read
Marx and without teleology.
And I think in a lot of my Italian fellows
there is a, still some teleology,
when they think in terms
of immaterial labor and what
is the tendency, and so on.
- This is a time to mention
again, the book on Marx's Temporalities,
which is is a crusade against
the teleological reading.
Okay, there's a couple of other questions.
One is a comment. But
why don't we do these two
and then we'll call it a night.
This is Phillip Walshshutter.
Phillip do you want to
present your comment question?
- Can you hear me?
- [Paul North] Yes.
- Okay, hi, Marx, greetings from Red Bay.
I'm very taken with
your focus on the body,
and this sense of how capitalism tie,
you become an appendage of the machine.
It formats your time.
It's a focus that I see
in your work and postone
and a lot of different people.
And it's a focus away from a
mode of attacking capitalism
which starts to establish
exploitation by trying to trot
out quantities and doing
mathematical equations,
like so many hours are stolen each day.
And that seems to be right on the terrain
that neoclassical economists
love, because it can end
in some endless dispute,
but when we're focusing
on what happens to the body and the fact
that it's limitless and it never stops,
it's going on and on which means,
you're going to work all your life,
and if there's a COVID
plague and you're a home
and you risk dying, they're
gonna push you to get out,
so you could work.
It seems to me that that
particular focus in Marx,
and it's all there in this
notion of capital as this kind
of automatic MCM prime generator,
that just keeps on going,
and yeah, it doesn't really
care about your body.
It's the skin that has
labor power around it,
and if it could extract
that it would do it
but it's quite happy to work you to death
and have someone else.
So it seems to me that your entire focus
is a much more effective organizing angle
just in terms of trying
to make people realize
what capitalism is, and
what can't change about it.
Which is precisely the limitlessness.
That's kind of found still
in drive to keep going.
So it's more of a comment than a question
and then encouragement saying as always,
I wait your next book Marx.
(laughs)
- Well, thank you Philip.
Yeah.
You know especially after I
published Marx Temporalities,
I had the opportunity to go
back to Marx again and again,
but it wasn't more about the,
what is the political stake in this book?
How we can probably read
this book today politically.
And as I said and I think
it was pretty clear,
at the end of my presentation,
I think that we have a
problem, and the problem one
we have many problems,
political problems and economic problems.
But one of them is that,
we think politics in terms of empty.
Once I asked my students,
"okay, so you don't like the
capitalist model production.
"Now what?"
We want to, abolish the value.
What does it mean?
I'm serious, what does it mean?
Oh, we want to stop the
valorization, but what does it mean?
I really don't know exactly what it means.
We don't want to produce commodities.
Yeah, why, how?
It's kind of, so we have a list
of things which denote the
capitalist mode of production.
And we think that by
attacking all these pieces
in the list of things,
we have something else.
I'm not sure about that.
For that reason, my conclusion
was, "Look I think that Marx,
"could have write this book,
"because in the 19 century,
"he could see an attendative associations.
"How workers organize themselves.
"How they organize their whole
life in a different way."
So that was the positive
thing is not only empty.
They had a kind of a pre
figuration anticipation.
You can call it whatever you want,
but they had an alternative in action.
And that was a theory in practice.
Marx has only to develop the theory
that was already embedded
in their practices.
I think today we should
do something similar.
Where is now the anticipation
of a different form of life.
And we have to extract theory from there,
instead of developing a
new theory of the empty,
capitalist mode of production.
Or we the entire humanity
should be against
the capitalist mode of production,
because we are all exploited.
Does it work?
Without associations, without
real forms of workers,
does it work?
Then people started dreaming,
"Oh, but we need a party."
Okay, sorry I become polemical.
I don't want to be because
I agree with the feeling,
otherwise, people think I
am disagreement with them.
I agree with him, but I
think we have open questions.
I think today we have a
much more open questions
than answers.
And I think when we read this
book, Capital volume one,
we should define the
questions more than answers.
- I want to give a chance
for Alessandro Fornazzari,
to ask a final question.
Can we unmute Alessandro?
- [Alessandro] Yeah, hello.
So I had a question regarding
the move from circulation
to production, that in the chapters
that you were working through.
We get this move from leaving
the sphere of circulation
into the hidden abode.
The promise that the secret
is somehow isn't a factory.
And I guess I'm wondering,
up to what point do we
need to relativize that?
And I'm thinking is circulation
necessarily the sphere
of mystification?
And then if that's the case, what do we do
with volume two, which
is sort of an intensified
return to the sphere of circulation?
- Yeah good question.
There is an elegant way to answer.
And I borrow,
maybe something from Tomba's
who brought the book on
time, in Marx Capital.
One can say that there are
three layers not stages.
Three layers of analysis.
In capital volume one Marx
is trying to understand time,
at the level of a production.
How time is crucial in
the valorization process,
but within production.
In the volume two,
is understanding how time is dominating.
Is a crucial in the circulation
and competition of capitals.
And then we have a Capital volume three,
in which Marx combines these two levels.
And basically he develops,
he really develops an idea
of a competition of capitals.
And I think this is very
innovative even for Marx himself,
because when he brought the Green resa
which are I go back to polemical point,
which are basically the text
that the people who are talking
about immaterial labor, law.
In the Green resa you don't
find the competition of capital.
Marx is working, Mika and Eilish
that I think he would come
to give a paper.
He wrote an article about that.
In the Green resa, Marx is talking
about capital in general,
he's very abstract.
It's like there is only one capital.
Then in the 61, 63, he
developed his ideas,
and he understood that the
actually there is not such
a thing as a capital in generals
but there in general, but
there are many capitals.
And then he has to address the real issue
of the competition among these capitals.
And this is what makes
things extremely concrete.
So my answer is we have
to read these three books
as a three level, three
layers of analysis.
In which in a certain way you find,
the concrete analysis of many
capitals in the world market,
in the third volume.
But it's just that,
its a kind of a way to
develop his analysis.
But then, and then it's
possible to go further.
But then we're going philology,
because it's also true
that the Marx brought Capital
volume three before volume one
and there are many different issues.
And then one can ask him, why
did he stop writing capital?
And some people say he
stopped writing capital
after the parties commune.
And then he was more and more
interested in none capitalist
for most forms of society.
He start reading a lot
of India, and the commune
and the common possession,
and in the villages.
On Russia and the Optina,
and me, he started reading
history and the non-capitalist
forms of production.
Why short time?
So because I think he
had the to understand
what an old capitalistic
society should look like.
And second question,
how is possible to skip
capitalists in society
which are not organized in a
capitalist mode of production.
And that was a crucial question
because there were people who claim
to be Marxist who thought
already in the 19th century
that it was necessary to go
through every single stage.
And in order to achieve social reason
first you have to be happy to is society.
And Marx was in doubt.
And in that a beautiful
letter to the authority
he said, actually, it's not true.
You can use the Russian option just
in order to skip the
capitalist mode of production.
So why am I saying that?
I'm saying that just in
order to emphasize one point
the project is an open project.
There is no way we can read
this book dogmatically.
It's an open project.
And I think today we
should find questions,
more than answers in this book.
And yeah, this is what I think.
- Thank you so much.
That's really, it's the first,
I think hopeful presentation
on Marx that I've ever heard.
And I can see a whole other texts there.
So I really appreciate
that opening up a set
of positions from which
to critique capitalists,
that don't turn capitalism,
that don't turn it into a big monolith,
you'd have to destroy all at once.
Finding positions within it
that are already outside of it.
I think that's really helpful.
So I wanna thank you on
behalf of everyone who's here.
This is another time where
there would be plenty
of applause.
You'll see them hands clapping,
and thanks again for coming.
- Thank you very much.
And thank you for your
comments, your questions.